on va parler du pire jeu du monde
nouvelle épreuve dans la bataille des
couples et on sent que c'est bien la fin
de la saison puisque on fait les fonds
de tiroir à mon avis les équipes
techniques sont au bout du rouleau ouais
ils ont peuvent plus d'être avec toute
cette équipe
donc ils n'ont plus d'idées alors ils
balancent tout ce qu'ils ont en stock
pour créer un jeu d'urgence voici les
preuves hacker a eu lieu hier donc dans
la bataille des couples c'est les règles
les plus folles du monde regarde
l'objectif est simple résoudre une
énigme attachés l'un à l'autre et m'ont
apporté la réponse il faudra au
préalable kono couple franchissent une
série d'obstacles
ils doivent ensuite récupéré une boule
de pétanque et brisé une glace contenant
deux clés qui permettront au couple de
se libérer du lien qui les unit une fois
détaché
ils pourront découvrir l'énigme la bonne
réponse se trouve sur une plaque est
située en haut d'un mur que les couples
devront atteindre en se faisant la
courte échelle ou bravo jean taches
noires
je reçois beaucoup de sms concernant la
défaite ma mère est au bout de 7 mais
elle en train de me défoncer pourquoi
t'as pas retiré tab est tu as vingt
téléphones plus petits demain il faut
que tu le défonce la foule inquiète
dominique ans mais c'est rien vraiment
elle est à fond elle est là c'est là en
train de vivre un sale moment
joli nom mais l'oubli de là c'est un
drame dans la famille là c est là c'est
un truc de ouf
donc voilà au début ça j - mais bien
moins ça lorsque tu penses au jour des
missions qu'un les règles étaient plutôt
simple finalement is it était attaché il
fallait simplement se détacher trouver
le code répondre à l'énigme est monté le
haut d'un proton est venu chercher ça
t'a pas sexy ce que j'ai vécu c'est vrai
je m'enfonce et toi toi tu bois sunu tu
me tente pas une perche à la main sur un
tu passes en pédalo tu me crachent à la
gueule bravo aujourd'hui petit focus sur
mais mélanie elle est belle elle est
charmante elle est drôle mais à mon avis
elle boit un peu trop voilà de trucs
voilà qui qui qui l'excitent voyou pas
dans deux secondes elle pas en cacahuète
et même son copain vincent n'a plus le
courage de la calmer alors vous allez
voir mélanie elle fait un peu peur mais
rassurez vous mine de rien elle est
gentil je la connais on la connaît
mélanie c'est une amie de benjamin
castaldi à baho bon tracé de monaco
n'est pas du tout vous habitez ou je
suis pas ami avec ben ali
ouais mais alors vous êtes amis les kits
saab avec d'autres personnes mais pas m
c'est qui votre meilleur ami jean
philippe monnier agents film honey mon
précieux témoin ah non vous êtes mon
frère
pendant ce droit
[Rires]
jeudi c'est la dernière fois qu'on se
défonce mans cerdan le les plus gras
faut lui dire ce qu'il est vraiment
sérieux il est vener sa mère l'a dit il
se dit est-ce que je passais à la
revanche avant la fin d'émission
oui c'est vrai est ce que cette défaite
est une pompe sera annulée du replay
jamais
cette défaite on ait réglé quoi faut la
laisser à bravo bravo après on peut la
première voiture à avoir joué les
envoyer en vacances qui vont occuper moi
même règle à destination tu vas tu vas
voir un petit peu tout va alors regardez
mélanie et l air mais regardez
[Musique]
donc la balle on envie de se venger on
va se manger au mène la bataille
commence
[Musique]
tata je vous aime et je peux
deux passerelles au ski et à ma mère qui
est encore réagi et l'idée à castaldi
désolé cas ça mais on n'a pas des petits
yeux comme ça dans la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça paraît simple fait partie des génies
du paf
alors on est tous des génies du paf et
serait toujours dans cette émission sur
tf6
c'est fx à la chaîne oui je me serais
jamais à ce nombre sans rien et fx quoi
quoi personne qui ferait avancer tnt un
temps ils ont toujours aidé non bataille
navale eux alors jamais compris cette
chaîne alors il ya la maxime et alizée
qui nous expliquer leur stratégie pour
ne pas être éliminé du jeu alors on va
pas se mentir on n'avait rien compris du
tout et aujourd'hui c'est au tour de
dylan et fidji d'expliquer par a plus b
comment ils vont gagner connaissez dylan
et fidji voilà ça c'est fait jean ça
c'est dylan dylan on le connaît on aime
bien on peut style and alors chez vous
essayez de comprendre la stratégie de
dylan moi j'ai regardé dix fois la
séquence
le seul truc que j'ai compris c'est
comment avoir mal à la tête et regarder
puis dumont en arriver là on est arrivé
là où on est moins jusque là mais
heureusement on est sorti mais là on a
pu remonter la pente
ensuite on tenait et si le plus mince et
on a monté la purger les clauses sur les
minimes ont augmentés là maintenant
c'est simple on va aller là pour gagner
la faveur des batwas c'est là qu'on voit
qu'ils sont très drôle parce qu'ils
m'ont quand même chercher des feuilles
ils font des graphiques
ils font des petits camembert et tout on
voit qu'ils jouent le jeu à fond tu
penses tu ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait
ça car c'est un cap et occupation est
bien sûr que ça vient d'eux
pour une fois que kanye agathe son corps
d'accord sur un truc pour moi donc c'est
vrai que ça fait plaisir
ma mamie tu as tu as regardé ça toi oui
mais moi je vais voir des jeunes quoi
effectivement bien évidemment c'est la
prod qui fait ça d'accord et c'est un
ami ou quoi c'est la barbe est typique
en tout cas ton d'humour et restons pas
piqué des ce qu'il ya de plus important
dans un couple et que benjamin castaldi
n'a jamais su mettre en application et
justement dans le couple fanny et nani
et chauffe le gat
alors pour assurer sa chérie famille
essaie de la convaincre
voilà le problème c'est que fanny la
fidélité c'est comme castaldi et le
mariage à crédible à maquereau
testiculaire
[Musique]
aussi me dis pas qu'à vous de vie des
déchets mairie on m'a pas sur marseille
et vous le savez quand on est trop fort
à l'école on saute des classes qui a
déjà sauté des classes ici ah non non
personne n'à ceux des deux caves ou une
moyenne section moyenne section
maternelle soit c'est ça je te dirais
alors moi aussi parce que j'étais grand
bain si elle était grande de taille et
intelligente
au nom de quoi je vous ai juste dit que
j'ai sauté une classe parce que j'étais
content mais c'est plus j'ai stationné à
quoi j'ai stationné mon art de ben quoi
deux fois le 6 juin non voilà 5e non
c'est pire que moi vous avez déjà un
problème et après
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
polly et moi et vous c'est je saute et
les classes l'écrit laquelle je
souhaitais pas malade et à ce jeu là les
trois enfants des classes
[Rires]
il
et ben non parce que je voulais dire
dans les marseillais sur w9 c'est l'
inverse quand on n'a pas la moyenne on
finit là bas voilà je vous le dis et
alors je vous dis attention gros scoop
les marseillais sont réconciliés avec la
langue française
non666 et pour élever le niveau de
l'émission il ya nos amis ont utilisé
des expressions presque française c'est
à dire que ça part très bien que ça
finit toujours très mal vous allez voir
vous a fait le top 3 de ce que vous ne
verrez pas dans le petit larousse 2020
ce sera dans un instant je vous avais
parlé des trois le top 3 des expressions
des marseillais y regarder
et la carte aux bottes merci bravo à toi
maintenant on parle nouveau pied
[Musique]
et en trois ans ça ne s'est jamais vu
est ce qu'on s'est pas çi riz est une
dingue pierre lujan cours
[Musique]
j'étais seul avec toi voilà je te le dis
parce que non il faut que l'on doit une
fière chandelle
c